[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم عبد القادر
عياط في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى في مناطق مختلفه من العالم
البدايه من انقره بعد ساعات من هجوم
استهدف مديريه الامن العام اعلن حزب
العمال الكردستاني مسؤوليته عنه
ثم الى البيت الابيض من هناك قال الرئيس
الامريكي
ان سياسه حافه الهاويه يجب ان تنتهي ينبغي
الا تحدث ازمه اخرى وذلك بعد اتفاق توصل
اليه الكونغرس قبل ساعات من اغلاق
المؤسسات الفيدراليه الامريكيه
ثم الى لندن حيث قال سونك ان بريطانيا لا
تخطط لارسال قوات الى اوكرانيا حاليا
متراجعا عن تصريحات وزير الدفاع الذي اشار
الى ان القوات قد تنفذ تدريبات في
اوكرانيا
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
بعد تبني حزب العمال كردستاني هجوم انقره
وزاره الدفاع التركيه تقول انها دمرت 20
هدفا للحزب شمالي العراق واردوغان يتعهد
بالقضاء على من وصفهم بالارهابيين داخل
حدود تركيا وخارجها
من شرقي وجنوبي الخرطوم الى ام درمان
وشمال كردفان معارك عنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وفي احدى
جولاته البرهان في دونجل الحدوديه
الشماليه السودان قادما من عطبره مقر
قياده سلاح المدفعيه السوداني
وسط جدل واشارات متباينه بشان الدعم
العسكري
يقول ان واشنطن لن تتخلى عن اوكرانيا رغم
اتفاق تجنب الاغلاق يقول ان بريطانيا لا
تخطط لارسال قوات الى اوكرانيا حاليا
يتوعد اي قوه تدريب بريطانيه في اوكرانيا
قد تكون اهدافا مشروعه
في اول مهمه من نوعها منذ نحو 30 عاما
بعثه من الامم المتحده تصل الى كاراباخ
لتقييم الوضع الانساني ومنظمه الصحه
العالميه تقول ان مئه الف من ارمليم رحلوا
الى ارمينيا
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصائد على
منصاتنا الرقميه كنا قد شاركنا معكم
التداعيات المحتمله للهجوم الذي وقع في
انقره اليوم الاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا
الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي
طبعا قبل اعلان عن غارات تركيه شمالي
العراق جاءت تساؤل كالتالي كيف سيكون رد
تركيا على الهجوم الانتحاريه الذي استهدف
مجمعا امليا في وسط انقره وجاءت ردودكم
على النحو التالي
27% قالوا ان تركيا ستشدد التحصيلات
الامنيه بعد الهجوم
وثلاثه وسبعون في المئه اشار الى ان تركيا
ستتحرك خارج الحدود
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقمي ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
طبقا لنتائج تحقيق حكومي تقصير جسيم وراء
حريق حفل الزفاف في العراق ووزير الداخليه
يعلن اقاله مسؤولين محليين واتخاذ اجراءات
اداريه بحقهم
[موسيقى]
ملك كردستاني مسؤوليته عن الهجوم في انقره
اليوم اعلنت وزاره الدفاع التركيه قبل
قليل تدمير 20 هدفا لمن وصفتهم بارهابيين
حزب العمال الكردستاني
غارات جويه على معاقلهم شمالي العراق
واضافت الوزاره في بيان لها انها تمكنت من
تحيد العديد من الارهابيين خلال الغارات
الجويه التي نفذها الجيش التركي
معنا من انقره مراسله الجزيره فرح الزمان
شوقي فرح ماذا عن هذه الغلط وكذلك ما جاء
لسان وزير الداخلي فيما يتعلق بهويه احد
منفذي هجوم هذا اليوم
هذا هو الرد التركي على ما حصل اليوم في
العاصمه عن قرا تتحدث وزاره الدفاع عن
تنفيذ المهارات الشماليه العراق نتحدث هنا
عن عدد من المناطق جبال قنديل غارها
الحديث في بيان وزاره الدفاع التركيه
تقول انها استطاعت ان تحيز الاصطلاح
المستخدم في وزاره الدفاع التركيه عدد من
المقاتلين المنظمين
الكردستاني
تدمير ذخائر واسلحه موجوده في تلك المنافق
واسعه على معامل هذه التنظيمات التي
تصليحها القلم الارهابيه
الامر ليس فقط بالمساله الرد على
الهجوم الذي
وانما تصفه بانه ياتي
الماده الواحده والخمسين الامم المتحده
والتي تسمح بالرد بحسب التركي ايضا احاله
تحديد الامن القومي بالتالي وزاره الدفاع
التركيه تقول بان هذه الغارات اهدافها هو
القضاء على الارهاب
فيها ما بعد وقوع هجمات تستحدث الشارع
التركي
والقنوات التركيه وايضا تجعل لتحقيق امن
الحدود التركيه
الشماليه العراق مستمره منذ فتره لكن
لاحظنا تكثيف هذه العمليات كثيرا في
الاونه اخيرا
تحديدا يعني نستطيع القول منذ شهر حزيران
او ثمود او خاصه في منطقه تسميها تركيا
منطقه عمليات المخلب او التي تشمل
الفتره الاخيره تحديدا في الشهر الاسير عن
تحيدي قاده من في الشخص الثاني فيما يتعلق
بمجرد الداخليه
اعلنت قبل قليل وقبل الصدور بيان وزاره
الدفاع مباشره
هويه احد
منافقين هجوم اليوم وقالت انه ينتمي لحزب
العمال الكردستاني وما زالنا
اخر نحن نعرف ان احدهما
نفسه والاخر
قدره واخيرا تؤكد الداخليه التركيه
للسياره التي استخدمت تركي من منطقه قيصري
سرقت التي استقلها
من انقره
هذا وقالت وزاره الداخليه التركيه انه تم
التثبت من هويه احد منافذي الهجوم وهو احد
عناصر حزب العمال الكردستاني مضيفه ان
المهاجمين قتل او قتل مواطنا تركيا
واستولى على سيارته لتنفيذ الهجومي بها
هذا وكان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
قال ان الدول العظمى حرضت منظمات ارهابيه
على تركيا لكن انقره تمكنت من القضاء
عليها واكد اردوغان في افتتاح الدوره
الجديده للبرلمان ان بلاده ستقضي على اخر
ارهابي داخل حدود تركيا وخارجها
[موسيقى]
استيقظت انقره على صوت انفجار لم تسمع
مثله منذ سنوات تحديدا في كيزيلاي حيث قلب
العاصمه ومركز مؤسسات الدوله شخصان يصلان
بسياره الى بوابه مديريه الامن التابعه
لوزاره الداخليه التركيه يفجر احدهما نفسه
وتقتل الشرطه الاخره النتيجه اصابه شرطيين
وعثور على قنابل واحزمه ناسفه فجرتها
السلطات
لاحقايند فور نزول الارهابيين من السيارات
تسدت لهما قوات الامن الداخلي واثناء
نزولهما فجر احدهما نفسه وتمكنت قوات
الامن الداخلي من قتل الارهابي الثاني
رغم ما حصل وفي مكان
وهجوم عقد البرلمان التركي اولى جلساته في
السنه التشري
عيه لم يكن توقيت ما حدث عبثيا كما قالوا
هنا فحتى وان لم تصل شظايا التفجير الى
مقر البرلمان فان رسائله تردد صداها تحت
قبته
تركيا دفعت منذ اربعين عاما اثمانا باهظه
جراء الاعمال الارهابيه وقد قضينا على جزء
كبير من خطر الارهاب فيما يتعلق بعملياتنا
خارج حدودنا على وجه الخصوص وكما تعلمون
القوى الامبرياليه سلطت علينا تنظيمات
ارهابيه حاربناها ونريد ان نقضي عليها
تماما
مر اقل من عام على هجوم شارع الاستقلال في
اسطنبول الذي نفذته وحداته حمايه الشعب
الكرديه عوام مرت على هجمات مماثله في
انقره نسبت المسؤوليه عنها لحزب العمال
الكردستاني او تنظيم الدوله لا يخلو زمان
ومكان الهجوم الاخير من دلالات
الرساله مواجهه الى نواب يشكلون الاغلبيه
في البرلمان كالرسوا انفسهم لمكافحه
الارهاب وياتي الهجوم مع تقدم العمليات
النوعيه ضد مسؤوليه التنظيمات شمالي سوريا
والعراق وبعد كلمه اردوغان في الامم
المتحده التي انتقد فيها دور الدول الكبرى
في دعم الارهاب
قساسه الاتراك حكومه ومعارضه على ادانه ما
جرى واتفق كثيرون على ضروره تحقيق تقارب
داخلي في بلد يمر بفتره استقطاب سياسي حاد
لمواجهه التحديات الراهنه خصوصا الامنيه
منها فرح الزمن شوقي الجزيره انقره
بعد منا ان قرا الدكتور احمد ايصال مدير
مركز اوسام لدراسات الشرق الاوسط الدكتور
احمد لنبدا بمنافذه الجيش التركي قبل قليل
في شمال العراق هل هو هذا المقصود مما
اشاره الرئيس التركي بانه سيتعقب من وصفهم
بالارهابيين داخل تركيا وخارجها
مساء الخير اولا اعتقد هذا الرساله ايضا
للارهابيين وداعميهم ان تركيا تقصف يعني
تلاحق
الارهابيين في الداخل وفي الخارج يعني هم
قضوا على على الارهاب تقريبا في الداخل
والان يعني يتم
حقيقتهم في الخارج في سوريا والعراق وعد
اعتقد هناك احتمال يعني هذه الارهابيين
جاءوا من العراق وهذا القصف ايضا يدل على
يعني
اصرار تركيا ان يحاربوا هذا يعني هذه
ظاهره الارهابيه
وحقيقه يعني كان كلام يعني شديد اللهجه
اليوم من اردوغان انهم يعني مصرون
وصامدون يعني بالنسبه لمحاربه الارهاب ولا
يعني يركعوا من هذه يعني تهديدات او
مناوشات يعني وفي الاخير تركيا من زمان
لكن الاخيره نجحت كثيرا يعني بدرجه كبيره
ضد الارهاب وحتى في
افضل يعني هذا النجاح دكتور احمد عن هذا
النجاح عندما يقول رئيس التركي بان تنفيذ
هذه العمليه دليل على ان من وصفهم
بالارهابيين يلفظون انفاسهم الاخيره ولكن
نوع الهدف وتاريخ الهدف الا يشيء برساله
مغايره لما قاله الرئيس التركي
الارهاب الان يعني يحاول ان يثبت انه
موجود يعني هو رساله حتى بالفشل كمان يعني
يبدو انهم ارسلوا
غير انحرافيين يعني لم ينجزوا بشكل بشكل
ممكن قوي وفشل وقتلوا يعني لكن هم ايضا
رساله من التنظيم الارهابي
انهم موجودين في الساحه وهذا غير صحيح
ايضا هم عاجزين جدا وبقي قليل منهم يعني
في السابق كان في حكي عن يعني 3000 ارهابي
الان يقولون اقل من 70 ارهابي من اعضاء
حزب العمال الكردستاني الدكتور احمد وصلوا
الى تنفيذ عمليه العاصمه انقره بعد كل هذه
السنوات تقريبا منذ سنه 2016 وتنفيذها في
شارع حساس وفي هدف حساس وفي يوم مميز
نعم هذا صحيح هناك ايضا يعني هذا الهدف
الرساله لكن هذا الشارع شعري العام يعني
لا مفتوح للجميع
للمواطنين للسياح الى اخره وليس مغلق يعني
هم لم يفتحوا شيء ولم يدخلوا في اماكن غير
قابله للدخول هم كانوا يمرون يعني مثل
باقي
النسائين وايضا ممكن المواطنين وهذا يعني
طبيعي لكن لم يستطيع ان يدخلوا في مبنى
الداخليه وفجاه يعني الا فجر انفسهم
والشرطه كان ايضا اخذ تدابير ورد
يعني رد بسرعه ولم يسمحوا لهم ان الدخول
اذن الرساله هنا يعني تنظيم الارهابي يقول
نحن او يحاول ان يقول نحن موجودين ولم
نموت لكن هذا ممكن انفاس الاخيره من من
حياتهم حقيقه انهم فشلوا جيشون اي حجمات
سابقا امس يعني السنه الماضيه فقط هم يعني
فجروا يعني شكرا ميدان تقسيم جابوا جابوا
ارهابي من سوريا ممكن هذه المره من من
العراق لكن حقيقه انهم يعيشوا صعوبه جدا
الارهابيون يعيش صعوبه
تركيا الدكتور مدير مركز اورسام لدراسات
الشرق الاوسط شكرا جزيلا لك
منذ انتهاء اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق النار بين
السلطات التركيه وحزب العمال الكردستاني
في يوليو عام 2015 تعرضت البلاد لعشر
هجمات وقد اتهمت الحكومه حزب العمال
الكردستاني بالوقوف وراء بعض تلك الهجمات
فبراير عام 2016 وقع انفجار قرب مقر
القوات المسلحه والبرلمان في قلب انقره
قتل فيه 28 شخصا واصيب العشرات ولم يتبنى
الحزب هذا الانفجار
مارس من نفس العام وقع انفجار هائل وسط
انقره كذلك خلف سبعه وثلاثين قتيلا ومئه
وخمسه وعشرين جريحه وقد اتهم الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حزب العمال
بالوقوف وراء الهجوم في يونيو من نفس
العام هزت هجمات محطه للحافلات لمنطقه
مزدحمه وسط اسطنبول قيل انه استهدف حافله
للشرطه واسفر الهجوم عن مقتل 11 شخصا على
الاقل في العاشر من ديسمبر من العام نفسه
هز انفجاراني مدينه اسطنبول مما ادى الى
مقتل سبعه واربعين شخصا بينهم 30 شرطيا
وسبعه مدنيين بينما اصيب اكثر من مئه
بالجروح وقد اعلنت تنظيم صقور حريه
كردستان مسؤوليته عن الهجوم
يناير من عام 2017 استهدف ملهى ليلي في
اسطنبول بهجوم بالرصاص خلال احتفالات راس
السنه مما خلفت تسعه وثلاثين قتيله كما
خلف الاعتداء ايضا تسعه وستين جريحه ولم
تتبنى اي جهه مسؤوليتها عن الهجوم
نوفمبر من عام 2022 وقع انفجار في ميدان
تقسيم باسطنبول مما ادى الى مقتل سته
اشخاص وجرح واحد وثمانين اخرين وقد اعلن
وزير الداخليه التركي حينها القبض على
سيده متهمه بالانتماء لحزب العمال
الكردستاني لكن الحزب نفى صلته بالهجوم
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
الجيش السوداني قصف بالمدفعيه صباح اليوم
مواقع قوات الدعم السريع في ام درمان
وكانت قوه الدعم السريع قد اعلنت سيطرتها
على حاميه عسكريه للجيش بولايه شمال
كردفان شمالي البلاد في الاثناء زار رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان مدينه
دنغلا عاصمه الولايه الشماليه بعد زيارته
مدينه عطبره في ولايه نهر النيل
بيومياتها الرتيبه والثقيله تمضي
المواجهات المسلحه في السودان دون اي
اختراق ميداني او سياسي في ام درمان قال
الجيش انه قصف مواقع قوات الدعم السريع
وسط المدينه وشرقها استهدف الجيش ايضا تلك
القوات في محيط سلاح المدرعات جنوبي
العاصمه الخرطوم وهو واحد من اهم مقرات
اسلحه الجيش السوداني وقد ظل من اولويات
اهداف الدعم السريع منذ اندلاع المواجهات
منتصف ابريل نيسان الماضي
قبل ذلك بساعات اعلنت قوات الدعم السريع
في بيان سيطرته على حاميه عسكريه للجيش في
منطقه ودعشانا بولايه شمال كردفان واصفه
اياها باخر حاميه عسكريه حدوديه مع ولايه
النيل الابيض قبل التقدم الى مدينه كوستي
على حد تعبير البيان
وتعليقا على ذلك قال مصدر في الجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان قوه ممن وصفهم
بالمتمردين هاجمت الجيش صباح الاحد في
المدينه ثم انسحبت منها بعد ترويع
المدنيين ونهب ممتلكاتهم على حد وصف
المصدر العسكري
وعلى وقع المواجهات وتوسع نطاقها الجغرافي
يواصل رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان جولاته الداخليه حيث حل
يوم السبت بمدينه دنغولا عاصمه الولايه
الشماليه
قائد الجيش السوداني زارا جرح المواجهات
الذين يتلقون العلاج في المستشفى العسكري
بالمدينه كما عقد اجتماعا مع لجنه امن
الولايه الشماليه قبل ان يتفقد معبر عرقين
البحري الذي يربط السودان بمصر على الضفه
الغربيه لنهر النيل
نرحب بضيفنا هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
مزمبل ابو القاسم الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي السوداني اهلا بك دكتور مزمبل
لنبدا بمقاربه هذه الصوره في مقابل الصوره
الاخرى رئيس مجلس السياده يزور يقوم
بزياره داخليه يلتقي بالناس في المقابل
الدعم السريع يسيطر على حامي عسكريه في
كردفان كيف نقرا المشهدين او الصورتين
تحياتي لك استاذ عبد القادر
زيارات البرهان التفقديه للولايات تستهدف
التحسس ما يحدث في هذه الولايات وانها
كانت الاكثر استقبالا للنازحين منا
العاصمه الخرطوم التي خلت تقريبا من
سكانها ما عدا محليه واحده فيهم درمان هذه
المدن تعرضت الى ضغط شديد بنزوح ملايين
من سكان العاصمه اليها واشياء الذي شكله
ضغطا كبيرا على خدماتها من خدمات العامه
مياه وكهرباء صحه علاج وغيره نتكلم عن
دونكولا وعبر اتكلم عن دونجولا وعبره وعن
منطقه ارجين التي تعتبر معبرا الى مصري
قبل هزار البرهان ولايه النيل الازرق
ولايه كسلا ايضا تفقد ولايه البحر الاحمر
حيث مستقره الحالي اما فيما يتعلق
[موسيقى]
هذه الزيارات فهي في تقدير تستهدف
التغطيه على الغياب الحكومي او الضعف
الاداء الحكومي على الاصح سيما وان العديد
من المراقبين من السياسيين انتقدوا هذا
الاداه لجهه ان الحكومه ظلت غائبه تقريبا
او ان الدوله ظلت بلا حكومه القرابه
العامين هذا الامر بدا منذ اواخر ايام
حكومه حمدوق حيث ظلت سته وزارات سياديه
خاليه بلا وزراء
يزداد المشهد عتامه بعد انقلاب 25 اكتوبر
الذي
تسبب في فراغ كبير في السلطه التنفيذيه
على وجه التحديد عاد حمدوق باشر مهام
الفطره بسيطه ثم استغل وبغيط الدوله منذ
ذلك الوقت بوزراء مكلفين الشيء الذي ادى
الى تصاعد المطالبات بتكوين الحكومه
الطوارئ او حكومه حرب او حكومه تصريف
اعمال تتولى العنايه بهموم الناس وتخفيف
اثار الحرب
وتضايعاياتها على مواطني الملايين
المتاثرين بها في الخرطوم وولايات اخرى
صيام ان هذه الحرب تمددت الى ولايات اخرى
مثلا ولايه نهر النيل جزئيا بدات تتعثر
بها في شقه شمالي الجنوبي ولايه الجزيره
ايضا بدات تتاثر بهذه الحرب في المنطقه
الشماليه منها اما فيما يتعلق بالشقه
العسكري في
الاشتباكات التي تمت
في مدينه او منطقه وضع شانه فهي منطقه
صغيره لا توجد فيها حاميه للجيش
واعتقد ان قوات الدعم السريع رجعت الى نفس
التكتيك الذي اتبعته في العاصمه في
العاصمه حاول تكرار على مدى اكثر من خمسه
شهور
الطرفين النقاط
القوات الدعم السريع حاولت ان تحتل
الحاميات الكبيره في العاصمه وفشلت فتمددت
جنوبا حدث الامر نفسه في ولايه شمال
كردفان حاولت ان تحتل حاضره الولايه مدينه
ابو ابيض وغرض عليها مرارا وتكرير او
تكرارا لكنها لم تفلح في في ذلك الامر
فتمددت شرقا
ومضت الى منطقه واد عشانا ومروبه وبدات في
تهديد ولايه النيل الابيض شكرا لك دكتور
مزمل ابو القاسم الاكاديمي والمحلل
السياسي السوداني
في التدعيه الانسانيه قال لمدير العام
لوزاره الصحه بولايه الخرطوم محمود القائم
للجزيره ان نحو 60% من المراكز الصحيه
بالولايه توقفت عن تقديم الخدمات بسبب
استمرار الحرب في البلاد
ولايه الخرطوم وكان فيها 54 مستشفى حكومي
الان العامل منها 23 مستشفى
والمراكز الصحيه في اكثر من 240 مركز الان
52 مركز صحي والشفانات في اكثر 130
والعامل اكثر من 100 الان يعني في الريف
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء البريطاني الى بلاده لا
تخطط حاليا لارسال جنود بريطانيين للتدريب
في اوكرانيا لكنه ترك الباب مفتوحا بحديثه
عن خطط محتمله مستقبلا حديث جاء بعد كشف
وزير الدفاع البريطاني جراند
لصحيفه تيليجرافت انه اجرى محادثات مع
قاده الجيش بشان نشر قوات داخل اوكرانيا
ضمن برنامج تدريبي
من الدعم العسكري عن بعد الى نشر مدربين
ومستشارين عسكريين على الارض وانشاء
برنامج تدريب عسكري بقياده بريطانيا داخل
اوكرانيا بدلا من كونه في القواعد
العسكريه التابعه لبعض دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي يقول وزير الدفاع البريطاني جراند
ان غرب اوكرانيا لن يكون بوابه للمدربين
العسكريين فحسب وانما ايضا لشركات الدفاع
البريطانيه يدعو الشابس هذه الشركات
لانشاء مصانع اسلحه في اوكرانيا يستدرك
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك تصريحات
وزير الدفاعه بالقول انه لا خطط حاليا
لارسال جنود بريطانيين في مهمه تدريبيه
الى اوكرانيا وان مقترحات وزير الدفاع رؤى
للمدى البعيد لا للصراع الحالي فحتى الان
ينقى حلفائه كييف في الغرب عن ان تطا
اقدام جنودهم ارض المعركه في اوكرانيا
تجنبا لاي صراع مباشر مع روسيا لكن حديث
المسؤولين في لندن يمكن قراءته في سياق
سياسه تبنتها بريطانيا منذ بدء الحرب
بالتقدم خطوه على الدول الغربيه الداعمه
فمع بدايه الحرب اعلن رئيس الوزراء الاسبق
بورس جونسون صراحه ان ما تريده لندن وتسعى
اليه هو هزيمه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين مهما كلف الثمن والمملكه المتحده من
ابرز الداعمين فمنذ بدايه الحرب تجاوزت
دعم البريطاني ثمانيه مليارات دولار وقد
تلقى نحو 30 الف مجند اوكراني تدريبا
عسكريا في اطار برنامج التدريب الذي تقوده
المملكه المتحده منذ عام 2022 في مارس
الماضي فاجات بريطانيا العالم بان كانت
السباقه قبل اوروبا والولايات المتحده
بارسال اربع عشره من دباباتها المتطوره
اثنين الى الجيش الاوكراني تلاهوا قرار
مفاجئ اخر في مايو الماضي بتزويد كييف
بصواريخ ستورم شادو وطائرات من دون طيار
هجوميه بعيده المدى ومشاركه بريطانيا في
تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه بدات فعليا من
روسيا شبه جزيره القرم ضمن ما يعرف بعمليه
اوربيتال المشتركه بين البلدين منذ عام
2015 اذ اشرفت القوات المسلحه
والاستخبارات البريطانيه معا على تدريب 22
الف جندي اوكراني في ذلك الوقت يقول
الرئيس الاوكراني السابق في تروبورشينكو
انه ورث جيشا متهالكا عندما تولى السلطه
عام 2014 لكن هذه القوات تبدلت احوالها
بفضل المساعدات والدعم الغربي
[موسيقى]
في المقابل قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي
ان تدريب بريطانيا عسكريين اوكرانيين على
ارض واراضي اوكرانيه يدفع نحو حرب عالميه
ثالثه واكد ان المدربين العسكريين
البريطانيين سيتحولون الى اهداف مشروعه
عند وصولهم
واشار الى انه في حال تزويد كييف بصواريخ
فاوروس لضرب روسيا فان الهجوم على مصانع
انتاجها الالمانيه سيكون متوافقا مع
القانون الدولي
بجانبه قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان
بلاده لن تتخلى عن دعم اوكرانيا وشدد في
كلمات له بعد التوافق على تجنب الاغلاق
الحكومي وغياب بند المساعدات الى اوكرانيا
عن الاتفاق شدد على ان واشنطن لن تتخلى عن
الشعب الاوكرانيه
حديثوا بايدا عن المساعدات يتزامن مع بدء
بعض دول جوار اوكرانيا بالتراجع تدريجي عن
لعب دور الداعم الدائم
تحولات في السياسه الخارجيه لدول جوار
اوكرانيا بدات تطرح علامات استفهام عن
ديمومه عقد الحلفاء بشكله الحالي
متغيرات بدات اوكرانيا تلتقطها وتعد
لسيناريوهات بديله تمكنها من استدامه
قدرتها على القتال
سلوفاكيا دوله الجارا نقلتها صناديق
الاقتراع الى موجه لا تسير بتوافق مع كييف
انتخابات فاز فيها حزب الديمقراطيه
الاجتماعيه اليساري ومرشحه رئيس الوزراء
السابق روبرت ريكو فوز يعني ان السياسه
الخارجيه والسياسات الامن والدفاع
ديبراتيسلافا ستتخذ منحا مختلفا برنامج
فيكو الذي حصد الفوز وفقه يستند الى وعد
من الرجل بعدم ارسال قطعه ذخيره واحده
لكييف ودعوه لتحسين العلاقات مع موسكو
وقبل سلوفاكيا سددت بولندا التي تقف على
ابواب انتخابات مرتقبه ضربه موجعه
لاوكرانيا وارسو التي قادت منذ بدء الحرب
ما يوصف بتحالف الصخور الداعم لقياف بدات
تتراجع وبحسب رئيس الوزراء توقفت بلاده عن
تسليح اوكرانيا للتركيز على تعزيز قوتها
الدفاعيه لكن المؤشر الابرز الذي يقلق
كييف هو ما جرى في الكونغرس الامريكي قبل
الاغلاق الحكومي بالساعات اقر الكونجرس
تشريع تمويل مؤقت للحكومه الفيدراليه دون
ان يتضمن اي بند لمساعدات الى اوكرانيا
فيما بدا مساومه بين الحزبين لتمرير
التمويل دون الدخول في خلافات حول ما يرصد
دعما لاوكرانيا وتخصيص مبالغ لمعالجه قضيه
الهجره غير النظاميه على الحدود الامريكيه
المكسيكيه اضافه
لمطالبه واضحه من الجمهوريين بمعرفه مصير
الاموال التي انفقتها واشنطن لدعم كييف
وتخوض اوكرانيا حربا مستنده بالدرجه
الاولى الى دعم غربي بالمال والسلاح ضمن
تحالف رمشتاين التي تقوده الولايات
المتحده ويضم 50 دوله بميثاق دعم عسكري لا
محدود لاوكرانيا في مواجهه روسيا
وتجاوزت تقديرات الدعم الغربي منذ بدايه
الحرب حتى يميو الماضي عتبه
166 مليار دولار ثمانيه واربعون في المئه
من المبالغ
ذهبت لاغراض عسكريه والباقي رصد دعما
ماليا لحكومه زيلنسكي وتقدر قيمه الدعم
العسكري بنحو 80 مليار دولار
تصدرت اداره الرئيس جو بايدن الداعمين
يليها الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتاتي بريطانيا والمانيا في المرتبه
الثالثه بين الدول الداعمه
[موسيقى]
معنا من وارسو الدكتور مارسين زبروفسكي
وهو عضو المجلس الاستشاري العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ البولندي ومن كييف
الدكتور
والدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه السابق اهلا بكم
ابدا بضيفي من الدكتور
واسالك ان كانت
او تشعر بالقلق فيما يتعلق بمدى التزام
حلفائها بتوفير الدعم المتواصل لهذه الحرب
التي تحتاج الى الكثير من الدعم من قبل
حلفاء كييف
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تحياتي تحياتي من
اوكرانيا صحيحه على اوكرانيا حول تقديم
المساعده عسكريه الاوكرانيا وخاصه اليوم
عندما فازت في سلوفاكيا الحزبالتي مواليلي
روسيا ناصر
رئيس وزراء لبولندي حول عدم تقديم مساعده
لاوكرانيا وكمان في ظل بعض
المخالفات داخل امريكا حول تقديم المساعده
الماليه لاوكرانيا ينبغي ادراك بين روسيا
دمرت اقتصاد اوكرانيا واوكرانيا اصبحت
للاسف الشديد
بالتلاقيه التي
معتمده جدا من الدول المانحه على كل حال
كما نحن كما نشاهد كان اوكرانيا بدات
انتاج السلاح الاوكراني اوكرانيا
حاول تاسيس شركه المشتركه
لانتاج السلاح الاوكرانيه نعم موجود
صعوبات ولكن نحن على يقين نحن سوف نجد
الحل في اقرب الوقت دكتور
ضيفي من وارسو هل مجرد خلاف تجاري بين
وارسو وكياف قلب اللغه في وارزو فيما تقوم
به روسيا في اوكرانيا تهديد لها بالدرجه
الاولى وبالتهديد للحلف الاطلسي الى اي
مدى
تغيرت اللهجه من قبل وارسو تجاهكير
اعتقد انها تغيرت حقا من الواضح اننا في
منتصف فتره انتخابات صعبه في بولندا
بالاضافه لنا في
موقف صعب في اوكرانيا
نفسها انها اوكرانيا تواجه صعوبات
اقتصاديه ايضا بالاضافه الى الحرقان هنالك
اختلافات بين اوكرانيا وبولندا فيما يتعلق
بتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى بولندا لان
الحكومه البولنديه تحاول ان تبقي قيودها
على مساله استيراد الحبوب لكنها
تبقى مساله الحدود والاراضي البولنديه
مفتوحه لنقل الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى بقيه
اوروبا بالاضافه الى خارج اوروبا وهذا هو
ربما الاهم المرحله الاهم لنقل الحبوب
الاوكرانيه ايضا المساله مدينه الحدوديه
البولنديه ايضا تبقلوا تبقى مفتوحه لنقل
[موسيقى]
البضائع وبالتالي والاسلحه عفوا التي تصل
الى اوكرانيا وتساعد اوكرانيا في الدفاع
عن نفسها هي تمر عبر الاراضي البولنديه
وبدعم من الحكومه البولنديه وهذا الامر لم
يتغير ولن يتغير وعندما ننظر الى
الاستطلاعات الراي العامه في بولندا ايضا
هنالك
قلق من استمرار
وهنالك ايضا
في مساله المساعده
خاصه بولندا استراتيجيا تشكل نقطه محوريه
فيما يتعلق بالحرب في اوكرانيا واي تغير
حتى وان كان لاسباب الانتخابيه سيؤثر بشكل
مباشر على طبيعه المعارك والمواجهات في
اوكرانيا وبالتالي ما تصور الحل
في حقيقه الامر لن يكون هنالك اي تغيير
كبير في السياسه في بولندا بولندا ستستمر
بتوفير
الامكانيه نقل الحبوب عبر الاراضي
البولنديه وبولندا ستستمر بخدمه دورها
والقيام بدورها كنقطه انطلاق لايصال
الاسلحه لن يتكون هنالك اي تغيير في هذا
الامر لكن هنالك خلاف ثنائي حول مساله
تصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه الى بولندا وهذا
الشيء يخشاه المزارعون البولنديونه فقد
طلبوا من الحكومه ان تحميهم من هذا الامر
وهذا
نحو ضيف الدكتور فيما يتعلق بحسابات هي
الان تقول بانها تعتمد على نفسها ولكن هل
تستطيع كياب ان تعتمد على نفسها في مواجهه
روسيا في حال وجود اضطراب من قبل
الحلفائها
[موسيقى]
يعني كل هذه الخلاف ينتهي بعض النهايه
انتخابات داخل بولندا التي سوف تكون في 15
منا اكتوبر اغلبيه
في الانتخابات
ومهم جدا
اي اتفاقيه
وفقا للاتفاقيه اوكرانيا اوكرانيا واتحاد
الاوروبي ولكن انا على اليقين نحن سوف نجد
حلل
مثل نحن وجدنا حل الواسطه
شكرا لك واعتذر منك الوقت من كيف الدكتور
الاوكرانيه السابق وكذلك الشكر لضيف من
وارسو الدكتور مارسين
عضوا المجلس الاستشاري للعلاقات الخارجيه
بمجلس الشيوخ البولندي
[موسيقى]
في اخر تطورات التحقيق في باسات حريق قاعه
الافراح بالحمدانيه في العراق قال وزير
الداخليه عبد الامير الشماري ان التحقيقات
اكدت ان الحريق كان عربيا وان سببه
استخدام العاب ناريه
هذا التحقيق هو تحقيق مهني
ومثبت بادله وضمن تصوير صور خاصه وكذلك
بناء على عينات ماخوذه من قبل الادله
الجنائيه والحاث مثل المستشار وحادث عرضي
وغير متعمد كل الحادث صار نتيجه اشتعال
القاعه بالعاب الناريه وتم توقيف اللي
موجودين صاحب القاعه الالعاب الناريه
هذا واعلن وزير الداخليه العراقي اعفاء
مسؤولين من مهامهم بتهمه الطقس
العميد زكريا احمد سلطان مدير قسم الاطفال
والسلامه في مديريه الدفاع المدني نينوى
من منصبه وتشكيل مجلس تحقيقه لعدم متابعته
لشروط الوقايه والسلامه وكذلك احاله مدير
الدفاع المدني في نينوى
الى اللجنه الى اللجنه الخاصه الرقم واحد
وتنفيذ تعليمات الحكوميه رقم للعام 2012
وتشكيل مجلس تحقيق بحقه لعدم قيامه
بواجباته
وصلت بعثه الامم المتحده اقليم الى اقليم
كارابا وفق الاتفاق الذي تم بين اذربيجان
والمنظمات الدوليه وتعد هذه الزياره
الاولى من نوعها الى الاقليم منذ 30 عاما
وتسعى البعثه الى تقييم الوضع في المنطقه
وتحديد الاحتياجات الانسانيه للاشخاص
الذين ما زالوا في الاقليم او الذين
يحاولون الخروج منهم
يحاول هذا اللاجئ من كربااخ استيعاب ما
حدث ايام عصيبه عاشها وزوجته قبل ان يشد
دار الرحال بما تيسر حمله من متاع وكثير
من الذكريات بعد رحله شاقه برفقه ابنهما
البكر وصل الى يريفان توفر شقه صغيره لاحد
الاقارب ساعد في التخفيف من تعب الطريق
يقول مافرك لكن الوجع يبقى اثقل على فراق
ارض قد لا يعود اليها ابدا
لا نثق في حكومه اذربيجان 50 ساعه
امضيناها في الطريق تركنا وراءنا كل شيء
فراق الوطن صعب جدا وذكرياته ستبقى معنا
الى الابد
تقول السلطات الارمنيه انها وفرت السكن
لاكثر من ثلث اللاجئين ورصدت نحو مليون
دولار لاستيعابهم وهو رقم ضئيل مقارنه
بعددهم الذي تجاوز 100 الف فيما اطلقت
برنامجا حكوميا لدعمهم يستمروا
ولتخطي الازمه تعول ريفان على دعم دولي
تصدرتون بتعهدها بمنح اكثر من 11 مليون
دولار ثم الاتحاد الاوروبي بخمسه ملايين
يورو وسبعه ملايين يورو من فرنسا رغم تلك
الوعود هناك مخاوف في ارمينيا من العبء
الذي قد يلقيه تدفق اللاجئين على اقتصادها
لكن تمت في المقابل ما يبعث الامل في ان
البلاد قادره بسواعد ابنائها على مواجهه
هذه التحديات
تغوص شوارع يريفان بنقاط كهذه لجمع
التبرعات
تضامن شعبي واسع يبرز تلاحم الارمينيين في
مواجهه ازمه اللجوء ارمني كاراباخ
قررنا عدم العوده الى كندا حيث نقيم حتى
نساعد الناس نجمع التبرعات لارسال المواد
الغذائيه والالبسه الى النازحين الموارد
لا تكفي لكننا سنواصل العمل وفي الشارع
ايضا يتواصل الضغط الشعبي على حكومه
نيكولا لا تكف المعارضه عن المطالبه
باستقالته بسبب سياساته في اداره الازمه
وتزيد وتيره هذا الضغط كلما اقترب موعد
لقائه مع الرئيس الاذربيجاني الاسبوع
المقبل في غرناطه الاسبانيه لبحث اتفاقيه
السلام
[موسيقى]
في ضوء استمرار نزوح سكان الاقليم من
الارمن بشكل جماعي
اقليم كندا البالغه مساحته 3200 كيلومتر
مربع يسكنه نحو 120 الف نسمه من قوميه
الارمن تفيد تقديرات فيريفان بان اكثر من
100 الف من هؤلاء عبروا الى الاراضي
الارمنيه منذ استعاده اذربيجان السيطره
على الجيب الانفصالي في الاقليم اواخر
الشهر الماضي وتتم عمليات نزوح اساسا عبر
معبر الحدودي قرب ممر لاشين وهو الطريقه
البري الوحيد الذي يربط اقليم كاراباخ
الاذربيجاني بارماني ارمينيا تفيد او
تنفيذ الاتفاق بين باكو والامم المتحده
وصلت بعثه الامميه الى كاراباخ في اول
زياره من نوعها منذ 30 عاما بهدف تقييم
الوضع وتحديد الاحتياجات الانسانيه للذين
يحاولون الخروج من الاقليم والذين قرروا
البقاء ايضا في هذا الاقليم وبينما تستمر
النزوح من كاراباخ اتهمت ارمينيا اذربيجان
بارتكاب تطهير عرقي بحق ارمن الاقليم بعد
عمليتها العسكريه التي انهت الانفصال هناك
وهو ما ترفضه باكو التي دعت الارمن الى
البقاء في الاقليم وتعهدت باحترام حقوقهم
لكن ماذا يقصد بالتطهير العرقي العباره
ظهرت خلال حروب البلقان في التسعينيات من
القرن الماضي على خلفيه انتهاكات القانون
الانسانيه الدولي المبلغ عنها في
يوغسلافيا السابقه لجنه الخبراء التي
انشاتها او انشاها قرار لمجلس الامن حينها
عرفت التطهير العرقي بانه سياسه تصممها
مجموعه عرقيه او دينيه واحده لازاله
السكان المدنيين التابعين لجماعات عرقيه
او دينيه اخرى من مناطق جغرافيه محدده
باساليب عنيفه لا يعد القانون الدولي
التطهير العرقي جريمه قائمه بذا
قناه الجزيره اهلا وسهلا
من المرحب به وصول هذه البعثه الاماميه
وجميع الضيوف الذين يرثون الى ارمينيا
ولكن هذا من قبيل الوقوف على الاطلال
والبكاء عليهم عندما يزورون منطقه جمهوريه
بعد تحديث سكانها الاصليون قصريا اكثر من
100 الف من مجموع 120 الف
ساكن
لجمهوريه ارصاف هجروا قصريا ماذا تفعل
بعث الامميه هل
تحصي البيوت الفارغه من سكانها
امم الان سوف تقف على ان كان هناك تهجير
قصري او تطهير عرقي اليس هذا كافيا
بالطبع ولكن ما تم قد تم لقد هجروا في
خلال الاربع والخمس ايام الاخيره التي
هجروا فسريا من مناطق سكنهم لم يحرك احد
ساكنا وحتى اثناء وقوع العدوان
لا احد حرك ساكنا والان بعد ان فرغت
الديار من سكانها البعثه الاماميه ماذا
ستفعل هناك انقل هذا السؤال ضيفي من باكو
الدكتور
عن فائده وصول هذه البعثه الاماميه بعدما
غادر اكثر من 100 الف من ارمن الاقليم
اقليم كرباخ
نعم لك سيد
عفوا
كان دعني اقول انه خلال
سنوات الثلاثين الماضيه خلال فتره
الاحتلال حوالي
اضطر اكثر من مليونين
لتركي منطقه كهرباء خلال السنوات الماضيه
دعوه دعت اذربيجان ممثله الامم المتحده
لزياره تلك المنطقه لكن ارمينيا منعت
هؤلاء الممثلين من زيارتي تلك الاراضي
اليوم العديد من الارمنين في كهرباء تركوا
المنطقه تلك المنطقه لكن كان هذا قرارهم
لم يجبرهم احد على تركي منازلهم كما
تعرفون ان وزير خارجيه اذربيجان طلبه قبل
يومين من الارمين ارمين ارمين
لا يتركوا منازلهم يوم امس
ممثل اللجنه الامم المتحده في الامم
المتحده قال ان الارميلين الذين يتركون
منطقه كارابا هم لم يواجهوا اي مضايقات من
قبل اذربيجان بالتالي فان الامر كان هو
قرار
الرمل
ان يتركوا تلك المنطقه وحكومه اذربيجان
قالت انها
تعرض
الجنسيه
الاذريه للمرمن
وعندما نتحدث ايضا عن ممثلي لجنه الامم
المتحده فان وزير الخارجيه يوم امس اصدر
بيانا حول الواجبات هذه البعثه
هل سيصبح للذين غادروا الاقليم باتجاه
ارمينيا العوده الى بيوتهم في كندا هل
ترجح ذلك
بالتاكيد فان حكومه اذربيجان مستعده
للترحيب بمواطنين وسكان الكهرباء اذا ما
قبلوا
جنسيه اذربيجان لان
قرب معترف بها دوليا كجزء من دولتي
اذربيجان اذا ما رفض السكان الارمن جنسيه
اذربيجان ما الذي بصطاعتنا ان نقوم به
واذا ما قالوا اننا ندعم الانفصاليين في
اذربيجان واننا ندعم التشكيلات العسكريه
غير القانونيه في اذربيج بوسعنا ان نقوم
فيما يتعلق بما قدمته باكو من ضمانات
لهؤلاء المدني ان يبقوا في الاقليم ان
يحصلوا على الجنسيه الاذريه وجود بعثه
امميه هذا اليوم في الاقليم اليست دواعي
كافيه حتى يبقى من بقي من الارمن في
الاقليم وان يعود من غادروا مره اخرى الى
منازله
عزيزي حسب القانون الدولي دعنا نوضح
الخطوات التي اتبعتها
اتبعها النظام الاذربيجاني
وضعنا لا نرجع الى التاريخ القديم فقط في
اخر ثلاثه سنوات
بدات في العام 2020 حربا عدوانيه باركتها
تركيا وسندتها بالقوه العسكريه واسرائيل
بعثت احدث اسلحتها
واستجلب النظام
الاذربيجاني فلول القاعده وجبهه النصره
وطالبان لكي تذبح الشعب المسالم في
الجمهوريه
هذه كانت بدايه
هذه الترتيبات التي الان تتحفنا بها
النظام الاذربيجاني
تاليا عندما دخلت المفا
وضات مرحله حسنه فيها
الحرب واوقفتها
لم تتوقف اذربيجان ابدا ان مخططاتها
لافراق السكان الارمن
كان هناك دائما مناوشات ودائما تهديدات من
قمه النظام حتى الى طلبت المدارس وحتى
ولكن دكتور جاره او ليس من السهل الان في
ظل وجود هذه البعثه الاماميه توثيق ما
تصفه بالانتهاكات والتهجير القصري عزيزي
فهمت ماذا تقول
البعثات الدبلوماسيه تاتي تاخذ الصور وثم
تغادر وتكتب التقارير
هناك كان لدينا بعثه من المفوضيه
الاوروبيه على الحدود بين ارمينيا
وجمهوريه
في بدء حتى قبل بدء
المعركه الاخيره العدوان الازربيجاني
الاخير تركت هذه البعثه مواقعها وهربت
اكثر من 100 كلم في العمق الارماني من
جمهوريه ارمينيا هؤلاء فقط هم شياطين
خرسان الشيطان دكتور ادركنا الوقت كنت
معنا من يربان عند الباحث المختص في
العلاقات الدوليه وكذلك الشكر لضيفي من
باكو جديد فالياف كبير الباحثين في مركز
تحليل العلاقات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
نتابع يوميات الاحداث في العالم وتطالعنا
وسائل الاعلام بصور صادمه من مناطق نزاع
او صراع هنا وهناك لكن تبقى افريقيا دوما
مسرحا لمئاس غير معلومه للكثيرين على سبيل
المثال ينبه صندوق الامم المتحده للطفوله
يونيسيف الى ان جمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه على سبيل العينه قد تسجل
العاب الجاري مستويات قياسيه لاطفال قتلوا
وجرحوا وخطفوا وواجهوا العنف الجنسي
للالعاب الثالث على التوالي وتقول الوكاله
الامميه ان عدد الانتهاكات الخطيره بحق
الاطفال يقدر باكثر من 1700 خلال النصف
الاول من العام الجاري الامر الذي يشكل
زياده بنسبه 41% مقارنه بالفتره نفسها من
العام الماضي واوضحت ان ذلك ياتي نتيجه
تصاعد اعمال العنف والنزوح الكثيف
والمسافه القريبه التي تفصل ما المجموعات
المسلحه والسكان مما يفضي الى زياده مقلقه
في حاله جرائم قتل الاطفال وخطفهم وتشويهم
يبقى الاطفال ضمن الفئات الاكثر هشاشه في
اتوني الحروب
ختام الحصاد الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]